[Music]
ryan i've got a list here of 15
minimalist home goods that add value to
my life
all right let's hear it i'm wondering if
they add value to your life and if
you're watching this on the live stream
patrons let us know if uh you think
these are minimalist items or maybe i
maybe have too much now
here's the caveat i own more than 15
things
at least 19 things but only 15 of them
add value to your life
these are 15 things that certainly add
value to my life i wrote down here i
think people are going to be surprised
by number five and number 15. number 5
and 15 will shock you that's right
they shocked me as i was writing them
down
i want to be clear though there's no
sponsorship here we don't do any ads on
our youtube channel we don't do any ads
on our podcast
these are not recommendations either i'm
not saying that you
should own these now keep in mind i
don't own much
and
that's because fewer things really helps
me stay calm
my physical space is a reflection of my
internal space so if i have a calm
exterior it helps calm
my interior so when i own something as a
minimalist it must add value to my life
i'm constantly asking that question does
this add value to my life and the truth
is that something that adds value to my
life today may not add value to my life
tomorrow and if that's the case then i'm
always willing to let it go i will say
this all 15 of these things they enhance
my life
but none of them make me complete ryan
i'm prepared to walk away from any of
these things yeah
at any time if they ever stop
adding value in fact i'm going to talk
about a story in a moment i'm going to
prepare to walk away from all of my
furniture um i'll talk about that here
shortly ryan because this curveball was
thrown at me recently i want to get your
thoughts on it i'm flattered by it but
also a little freaked out by it okay
we'll get to that in a moment i'll say
some of these items are essential in our
minimalist rule book ryan the
minimalists.com rulebook we have these
uh 16 rules for living with less one of
them is called the no junk rule
everything you own fits in one of three
piles it's either essential it's
non-essential but value-adding or it's
junk
those are the non-essentials that don't
add any value they simply get in the way
yeah i don't own any junk
okay and i make sure of it if something
does become junk then it i get rid of it
yeah another rule the 90 90 rule have i
used this in the last 90 days if not am
i going to use it in the next 90 days if
not it's probably junk and i'm going to
let it go and so all of these items are
either essential or non-essential
and
the non-essentials still add value to my
life i would say two of them are
definitely essential number four and
number eleven on this list are
essentials for me but even essential is
perspectival something is essential to
me may not be essential to you and vice
versa but all of these add value to my
life jordan as we're going through this
on the video if you could put sort of
over my left shoulder here i put a link
of each one a picture of each of these
items in here we'll put a picture on the
video version so you can see each of
these items that i own
ryan i want to see how many of these add
value to your life or maybe how many of
these things do you own number one
is my sleep master sleep mask
[Laughter]
that one is almost essential for me yeah
that's a good one i travel with it i see
both seans nodding their heads right now
yeah and uh the sleep i was gonna say
josh this is podcast sean here yeah i am
one that
if prior to you and i talking about it
yeah i always thought that was a
frou-frou thing like this
oh that's that's what that's what women
do to keep their delicate features yes
and then that's so funny after you and i
talked about it i tried it after i
bought mine
that's the best sleep i've ever had in
my life when i wear that thing yeah it's
significantly different if i don't wear
it
alabama do you use a sleep mask hell no
i toss and turn a lot they don't stay on
my face so i like this one well yeah it
does here's what i'll say about the the
sleep master sleep master sleep mask is
as soon as i started using i started
traveling with i use it every night
bex's sleep improved in fact most of not
most several of the things on this list
are sleep related
i see other sean here i have three of
those sleepmaster sleeves you do not one
lives under my pillow one in my carry-on
bag and then one in my backpack wow just
in case i end up sleeping just in case
the three most dangerous words you know
i've actually this is going to sound
even more maximalist but like i've
considered getting like more than three
of them because what i have i stopped
wearing mine because i get styes in my
eye
and it's because of the sleep mask like
that's what i have narrowed it down to
so i can wear it one or two nights in a
row but after that second night that
third night like it just it's dirty
enough to wear it so i was thinking
about getting a few of them so you know
like just like you know with underwear
yeah exactly like you know you've got to
have a few pair because you can't always
have one pair of underwear clean
um anyway so yeah so three that's not
bad at all all right guys we can't enter
we can't keep interjecting i want to get
through this whole list here
i will say that uh the sleep mask is
essential for sleeping for me it helps
my sleep significantly we'll put a link
to all of these items in the show notes
if you want to check them out on the
private podcast number two jordan we'll
put a picture here of the earpiece
earplugs are these same ear plugs that
you use no man i would be interested to
see
they're great
earpiece
p-e-a-c-e like ah peace yeah but they're
earpiece earplugs and uh as soon as beck
started using them she recognized like
and people like drummers and stuff use
these there's varying degrees of
sensitivities you can block out
virtually all of the hearing podcast
sean i think you might use those at this
point now or maybe your wife yeah after
uh you but my wife especially like i
tend to snore a lot
and it drives her insane so between the
sleepmaster sleep mask which she uses
now as well and uses those yeah i don't
bother her at all i have no affiliation
to either of these companies by the way
and again they may not add value to your
life here's an item that my wife owns
that i benefit from it is the marpack
dome classic original white noise
machine
so all right sleeping and she turns on
this white noise machine yeah it has
this little fan in it basically
and it it it's the best white noise
machines from all the rev reviews i've
seen and
she uses that
every night and
it just creates this calm white noise
environment yeah that sort of helps
promote sleep yeah
number four on the list i have a
sort of cheap mattress it's a extra firm
mattress because i had a bad back for a
long time and so i found this beautyrest
mattress which if you're watching the
video it's right here somewhere jordan
um
and that
that mattress
what i learned from it i bought it i
just checked the price on it recently i
think it's 699 bucks when i bought it
back in montana it was
400
and that mattress has been amazing for
me but i know for other people it would
be terrible it'd be way too far other
people lay on and they're like what is
this rock that i'm laying on
but for me it really helped with my back
pain before i found a gasket therapy and
really fixed my my back problems
number six ryan oh by the way i got one
more bonus sleep item at the very end
this isn't part of my 15. i got an extra
bonus sleep item which is my favorite
sleep item out of all of them so i'll
talk about that at the end but number
six perfect pull-up bar
yeah it's like 30 40 bucks but
it is the best 30 bucks i've ever spent
is that the one that drills into the
door frame it does drill into the door
frame and so every time it's a good one
i've had right over my my uh bathroom
every time i go to the bathroom i just
bust out 10 pull-ups really quickly yeah
i go to the bathroom a lot so every day
is like 70 80 pull-ups you and mariah
both
shows 80 pull-ups today at least
the pull-up bar because it's these
simple habits and before i used to need
some sort of amazing trigger to in order
to do pull-ups you have to go to the gym
and lace up your shoes and you have to
have the right workout shorts on and now
it doesn't matter i can be butt naked
and just walk right in the bathroom and
i'm doing pull-ups thankfully no one's
around seeing me doing naked pull-ups
number seven only your only fans
your only fan members get to see that
oh yeah we should film that
number seven
[Laughter]
number seven is
a uh plain white dining table from
hermann miller a lot of our studio
furniture is from hermann miller they
make really solid furniture that lasts a
long time and it's relatively
inexpensive this one was a few hundred
dollars and i think it'll probably last
me the rest of my life as opposed to
buying something from ikea that will
break down
after three or five years so
it costs more upfront but probably costs
way less in the long run yeah it's just
a real simple white dining table from
herman miller and that adds immense
value to my life because i'm sitting at
that table every single day eating meals
but also i prefer often to write
at the dining table if i'm writing
something creative i don't know why that
is if i'm getting regular work done i
can go to office or whatever but when
i'm doing creative writing i think
because for many years that's where i
started doing it i associate the dining
table with creative writing and so
having a nice table
that
isn't from ikea or somewhere cheap
really worked well for me yeah
oh you know i mentioned i missed number
uh
number four number five here we'll just
put it back here i have a
cheap but minimalist bed frame from
amazon
and so i do have a thing from amazon i
generally don't buy things from amazon
if i can buy them locally first
but i bought a relatively inexpensive
bed frame yeah it's just a simple
slotted bed frame it was like 110 bucks
from
amazon mariah and i have the uh
it's the adjustable
oh yeah frames those are tempurpedic i
am so old man like
we are old because we talk a lot about
how to get good sleep and i remember
you know when i was a teenager i got
good sleep regardless i used to sleep on
your floor all the time yes uh in the
cabin in lebanon and now
like every time i go camping i always
swear i'm like i'm never gonna go
camping again because i wake up with
such bad back pain but that adjustable
frame
uh and then you know add the mattress to
that like it really helps me get some
really awesome sleep and uh
very minimal minimal back pain
um but yeah yeah it's
and
this is how normal too mariah and i we
have uh it's two twin beds that go
together
so technically we sleep in separate beds
[Laughter]
[Music]
we just push them
together like a 50s couple on tv
exactly exactly wow and so what's nice
about this and this was the one the ones
this was number five i said i think this
would shock some folks because i'm
shocked that i would even buy a bed
frame from amazon but i had someone
recommend this one to me they're like
it's great you've got to check it out
and
and then i stayed at airbnb and they had
the same exact one
and i slept in the bed and i'm like oh
yeah
this works really well and not only does
it look nice but it's really simple
and so yeah i have a inexpensive bed
frame that works well for us and i no i
didn't buy it locally although i buy
most things locally it's the one thing
on this list that i bought from amazon
oh no there are two things i think the
perfect pull-up i either bought straight
from the company or from amazon yeah
anyway uh number eight probably what was
number five
the
bed frame was number five oh okay we did
six and seven already i backtracked
number five number eight is probably the
most expensive thing that i own in my
house is my couch
and it's from bow concept
and it's called the caramel couch it's
in beige or i put a picture of it right
here for jordan and um
what i'll say is
this
couch that i bought
is
i realized ryan when we were on tour in
2014 we didn't own a couch when you and
i lived together right at all right and
as we were touring we stayed at a lot of
airbnbs and i realized oh i
miss having a couch
and a living room in which to congregate
with friends and family when we are
meeting
and
it was the one thing i missed and i
recognized we're on tour i'm getting
value from this i don't want to deprive
myself of it and so buying the couch
that i want for the rest of my life yeah
took a lot of
figuring out i have a couch that's like
it wasn't that much like it was uh i
don't know it was 900 bucks or something
um but because of our cat like i refuse
to spend
any more money on a couch god love mac
love him so much
but man he loves the claw at the couch
like we have to put up no we have to put
like a cover over it yeah so um yeah
that's a purchase that i won't be making
you know for at least five years
but i do admire a good couch
yeah i mean
i enjoy it's a rather firm couch i enjoy
sitting on it i enjoy spending time with
my wife on the couch i enjoy reading on
it it's multi-function
i just like being on that couch it
really does add value to me and to our
space number eight on the list is oh
it's number nine actually the bookcases
i have the people always ask about my
bookcases because i've seen the home
tour or whatever it's called the tall
story bookcase
it's from design within reach they're
relatively inexpensive but they stack 40
to 60 books on them and they kind of
look like a piece of art because the
books vary in color and it adds some
variety to
the space
number 10 ryan
i have two paintings from beulah
beulah helped design this
studio space that we're in but she also
did two paintings for my daughter ella
and so in her bedroom she has these two
pieces of artwork from beulah that are
just beautiful we were moving she was
i'll ask
i don't want to keep all my toys but can
i can i please keep these paintings from
viewers
i'm like ella we're not going to make
you get rid of anything oh except all
your toys that's right
you're nine now grow up already that's
cool she's that young and can appreciate
art that's awesome absolutely
number 11 on the list to me this is
truly essential for me
it is the brio prism reverse osmosis
tankless water filtration system
it's an under-the-counter filtration
system
for drinking water yeah if you go to
ewg.org
tap water let's put a link to that in
the show notes you can see all of the
horrible toxins that are in your
drinking water i don't know if i'm
grateful for you introducing me to this
website or not because it's terrifying
it is terrifying and as soon as you
figure that out you'll find ways to
filter your water now ryan you use a
berkey filter yeah and the reason i use
reverse osmosis is berkey doesn't get
out enough of the things for me
for my preference and
reverse osmosis is also more
aesthetically pleasing you have to have
someone come out to actually install it
although you can do a countertop one as
well so there's a countertop option
although in my last apartment i had a
plumber come out and install it under
the sink there as well because i wanted
access to clean drinking water
every time i wanted water and i didn't
want to just drink straight from the tap
and that was the most cost effective
that way you're not buying these giant
five gallon
uh like we have them at the studio here
because we don't have a water source
here in the studio but i didn't want at
home to constantly buy in these five
gallon glass bottles i wanted to filter
out the toxins from the drinking water
so to me that of everything on this list
that is the
that in my mattress the two most
essential things
in my home yeah number 12 and 13 go
together
uh we finally upgraded ryan after our
kettle died to the fellow kettle
congratulations thank you mine has not
died yet
i finally feel complete
right no my kitchen uh kidding obviously
but my kitchen has nothing on the
counters except a really beautiful
grinder and a really beautiful
kettle both are from the company fellow
again no affiliation with them they just
look like pieces of art and everything
else we put into the cabinets there is a
storage space for everything so we have
nothing else on our counters except two
very beautiful appliances number 14 on
the list
is the i adapt hepa uv air purifier
now this served an even greater purpose
in los angeles we have one that's right
behind you you can't see it on camera
but we have one in the studio we have
one in the writers room downstairs i
have two of these at home
to filter out any of the toxins that we
breathe in i could certainly make a case
for this being essential in our
tox toxin ridden environment yeah
especially if we're living in a big city
the the pollutants that enter our homes
but also just the air in our homes that
is constantly being cycled if we're not
leaving our windows open it can be toxic
finally ryan number 15
this is the one you were all waiting for
it's the
elchem professional salon salon ceramic
hairdryer
i have a salon great i mean clearly if
you're watching the video version
a salon grade hair dryer
i know what you're thinking that's not
very minimalist of you and
i would agree the more minimalist route
would be to look like jordan or new sean
over here but i just don't have the head
for it i shaved my head once i saw a
picture of the back of my head
it looked like a picture of the moon
hey the moon's beautiful
[Laughter]
oh it's funny man yeah i uh i have a
hairdryer i hardly ever use it though i
i use it uh
when i'm in a pinch and i gotta like dry
my hair real quickly usually i just let
it air dry but yeah i've got like the
the one that actually you entered the
one you used to have the one he
introduced me to with the retractable
cord and it folds and the travel one
yeah yeah
finally ryan i got a bonus item for you
what's that the bonus item is we had
clint ober on the podcast a month or so
ago
i have a grounding mat for my bed i was
wondering if you were gonna yeah bring
those up now everyone in here sleeps on
a grounding mat except for maybe new
sean he hasn't gotten one yet but the
fine folks over at earthing.com they
never gave me mine i paid for mine just
to be clear but they gave everyone on
our team a
grounding mat to sleep on and i can tell
you that everyone in here has said
something
uh positive about the way that that has
improved their sleep danny was actually
talking to me this morning about he said
did you start having more more vivid
dreams
yeah and the truth is that if it
balances out your sleep maybe you
weren't getting enough rem sleep that's
the sleep in which you dream more maybe
you weren't getting a enough rem sleep
and this has helped balance out your
sleep it's helped my sleep immensely my
wife it's helped her sleep significantly
it's helped her nervous system as well
and so being grounded at night on a
grounding mat from earthing.com here's a
picture of one right here again no
affiliation i don't get any money for
telling you that i can just tell you
that it is truly essential for me now
whenever i travel i bring that grounding
mat with me yeah those are 15 minimalist
home goods that add value to my life
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit
patreon.com slash the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and youtube
channel 100
advertisement free